le souvenir est la clé le tout
sans lui nous sommes aveugles
sourire ils ont laissé au hasard décider
du sort de notre monde
m
je suis navré de vous déranger albus
mais je viens de recevoir des nouvelles
inquiétantes dites-moi qu'y at il à ses
greens de faste
notre moment est venu mes frères et
soeurs notre guerre contre les moldus
commence
aujourd'hui
le monde que nous connaissons s'effondre
enfin cru grindelwald des deux va me
faire confiance nous avons besoin de
vous monsieur kowalski jeudi je voulais
rester en dehors de ça
vous savez que je suis une sorcière nom
de mulder m'a donné quelque chose pour
toi jacques home
c'est l'équipe qui va détruire le
sorcier le plus dangereux que ce siècle
et connu
toutes les chances sont de notre côté
personne ne doit tout savoir pas même
vous
ce que tu fais est une pure folie
avec ou sans toi je vais anéantir leur
monde
les périodes dangereuses
pour le lit des hommes dangereux
si à l'heure du thé nous sommes toujours
en vie
alors nous efforts ont été couronnés de
succès monsieur kowalski avec plaisir
as tu vraiment l'intention de tourner le
dos aux tiens
[Musique]
c'est toi qui disais que nous pouvions
refaire le monde même si nous avons
commis des erreurs
tadjau
nous pouvons essayer de les réparer
nous allons avoir besoin d'être
[Musique]
quoi que tu fasses tu ne m'arrêtera pas
les apparences sont trompeuses
[Musique]
j'espère que vous êtes satisfait de
votre baguette monsieur kowalski
je peux la garder
[Musique]